hello everybody marklar here we have a
charity livestream going on today where
we're trying to raise $6,000 for Uno's
here's my workstation just in case you
roll over wondering is my computer over
there and are you ah
I'm Tyler buckle up to 12 on Twitch yet
mmm-hmm so what are we raising money for
today we're raising funny for a nose
which is the United Network for Organ
Sharing raising funny early oh yeah
we're raising funny anyway yeah so you
know who knows is United Network for
Organ Sharing like he said and it's a
what did it do explain it basically it's
an organization they raise money they do
research on how to make organ donations
better and they also run donate life
which is basically the charity that
helps out organ donation is that what
you're trying to get he he's not good on
camera oh that was my brother right
there what's up okay show him your scar
that's a scar showing your knee oh yeah
yeah so he just said he just had surgery
so he's the perfect example of a
sad-sack charity case so please stop by
he'll be there I'll be there playing
games and whatnot gray I'm going to try
to beat a lot of games on the hardest
difficulty so prepare for a lot of rage
anyway so hope you'll all be there and
thank you so much for watching and as
always let's do you over there bye bye